we do hope the open debate with the
broad participation of member states
uh
will provide an opportunity to discuss
ways to address risks to International
Peace and security stemming from
violations of the Agreements are not
electoral understandings
with regard to regulating export of
weapons and military equipment
we expect participants to consider the
negative consequences of non-compliance
by member states with their obligations
in arms and ammunition transfers and
identify ways to improve mechanisms for
controlling experts or weapons and
military equipment
just for your information we do not
intend to focus focus the discussion on
some specific country original
context but rather discuss the issue
from the nams control perspective the
first on the first question we hear
these comments of course
some countries are pretending they can
decide at their own will Who
who they want or do not want to be in
the chair of the presidency of the
security Council
as long as the current world order
with the UN and the security Council
stance there will be no change in the
rules of procedure
and the prep the in the order the
presidency of the presence is well
defined it's not for them to change it
uh on I heard also comments on on
that Russia should be known as broker uh
in the in the presidency of the security
Council I think
I think that nobody could approach us
that we were not one when we were in the
presidency which can easily be checked
unlike some countries who come up with
such claims who are not always honest
brokers uh
I'm not even talking about the comment
of the U.S PR
whose presence in the security Council
and I recognized it when they were was
professional but some of the uh
predecessors I would say
didn't do likewise and they played with
the rules and procedures of the security
Council and factually basically
trampled the council's rules and
procedures I also hear comments heard
comments from an outstanding and chief
European Diplomat Jose who recently
distinguished himself with comments that
and statements that made him a truly
International Star
invoking the the 1st of April Fool's Day
to that I will not comment much I will
be also I will also I will only ask a
rhetorical question who's talking
um rule 20 says during the consider
duration of a particular question
whether it's the member he represents is
directly connected he shall indicate his
decision to the council to to to recuse
yourself basically
um if if that particular issue is
something that you're directly involved
in and it's up to it's up to you as the
president to decide that so if the issue
of Ukraine comes up this month
does the provision for you then to hand
the presidency for that subject over to
Switzerland no is that no why not if uh
if you put the question this way then I
think if you are the countries that are
on the security Council should also uh
withdraw from that discussion and namely
uh three members of the P5 who are
directly involved involved in the
situation which you are alluding to uh
secondly I would like to remind that in
20 cell in 2003
boss UK and U.S were presence of the
security Council in September in October
consecutively
nobody raised the question of their
legitimacy to to hold the presidency and
nobody puts on the table the question
that they withdraw from discussing
issues an issue that was perhaps the the
most hot and topical then
um the U.S ambassador told us this
morning that she expects
the Russian presidency to be
professional
but she also
said that
the U.S expects uh Russia to be
spreading disinformation about Ukraine
could you respond to that
uh thank you
I I would agree with the first part of
the state of that statement
I think Linda was
correct and I hope that was not that not
that was not uh
that was not a question but uh
but uh but a statement that she expects
us to to act professionally experience
with Security Council which shared a
chance to uh to to get issued when we
were presents last time and that that
was the first presidency with us in the
Pres in the seat of the share of the
Securities so I will not uh disappoint
you on that uh on on the second part
that we are spreading this and will be
spreading using the pregnancy to spread
this information about Ukraine
that's uh that's uh
that's a statement that that is in the
in vain of of the western narrative that
Russia is doing nothing but spreading
this information about Ukraine in fact
we we think just the opposite and one of
the
one of the disinformation that the
Western media and and Western officials
are spreading
is the situation of Ukrainian children
who were allegedly kidnapped kidnapped
from Ukraine and and brought to Russia
to Russia against their will and this is
just one aspect but the area formula
meeting which I hope you will follow
will is intended to dispel this
narrative
and the so-called Russian disinformation
on the tissue there are many others of
course but I will not I will not stop
here to to cite all of them